here's another thing that made me a
really an advocate of psychoanalytic
thinking and it was the sort of thing
that started to terrify me about what
the human psyche was actually like I
started to understand that not only were
we like an amalgam of relatively
autonomous subpersonalities each of
which had the possibility of gaining
control but that we were also victim you
might say or beneficiary of impulses
that were beyond our conscious
formulation or or or understanding or
capacity to resist so here's this here's
a funny story so I was talking to one of
my patreon people online this week and
he said he's a he was a committed
atheist and that's fine you know lots of
atheists are very honest people and
they're atheists because they don't know
how to reconcile what they know with
traditional claims let's say and they're
not willing to just mangle them together
you know and there might be cynicism all
doubt associated with it as well but he
said he was he said he was entranced by
these biblical lectures you know which
is pretty weird and he said if someone
would have told him a year ago that he
was going to like be obsessed with a
sequence of biblical lectures he would
have told them that they were mad and so
we had a bit of a discussion about that
and because this is an interesting thing
you know and he mentioned this he said
it was something like you don't choose
your interests they choose you and
that's really worth thinking about to
man because you know it's really hard to
get interested in something you're not
interested in even if you know there's a
good reason for it
you know you're studying for an exam you
find the material boring you know
anything will be more interesting than
than the studying even though you know
that that's what you need to do you
can't voluntarily grab yourself by the
scruff of the neck let's say and shake
yourself and say sit down and
concentrate your mind will just go
everywhere but then if you're interested
in something and even if it's something
you shouldn't be interested in because
that happens all the time then it's like
you're a laser focus man you can pay
attention forever you can work until
you're exhausted you won't even notice
it and you remember everything it's like
okay if you can't control your interest
what does and man I tell you you can
think about that for a very
time so Jung talked about the spirit
mercurius you know Mercury's the winged
messenger of the gods and and here's how
he conceptualized it psychologically he
thought this is what the ancient people
who thought about mercury has the winged
messenger of the gods were trying to
state psychologically you know your your
interest Flitz around it's like there's
something that captures it and that
moves your interest from place to place
you know like if you walk into a
bookstore you'll get interested in a
particular book it's as if the book
grips you is you don't know why you're
interested in that you might but often
you don't know why you're interested in
that book and you know your interest is
flitting around and so that's mercury
the thing that makes your interest flick
flicker around is mercury the winged
messenger of the gods and mercury is the
messenger of the gods because it's the
things behind the scenes psychologically
that are manipulating your attention and
for Jung those were equivalent in some
sense to the lost gods and so for Jung
your your interest was being manipulated
behind the scenes by unseen forces that
were associated with your character
illogical development across time that
was the manifestation of the self so the
self is this the the potential you let's
say and the way it operates in the
present is by gripping your interest in
directing it somewhere and that's part
of the instinct of self-realization
it's a mind-boggling idea man really
it's